we've got a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a new caller I
have a feeling we might be hearing from
this guy frequently
yeah I listen to your show what a joke
right what a joke you need to wake up
have you been to a store lately yes
selves are empty
gas prices are doubled inflation's at 31
year High I mean what a joke you know I
don't I know you don't like Trump okay
that's good you don't like the way he
tweets or you don't like what he said
about bleach I mean really grow up be an
adult he had his foot on Putin's neck
okay so there's I think 11 is there I'd
have to go back I think there were 11
lies there
now you know I mean I've already spoken
about gas prices and it's a real problem
it's a problem in a number of ways it
just doesn't really have to do with Joe
Biden can North Korea under some
what a joke really I need to wake up you
and now you're listening to wake up and
you need to stop passing that propaganda
that Democratic propaganda you pass off
is reality I'm not even a Democrat yeah
we three three Trump one well or at
least he would have won if there wasn't
a pandemic and you didn't bend those
rules in your favor so you could drop
off ballots have car loads of people
pulling up you know have people mailing
in millions and millions of ballots I
think we're up to is it 18 lies so far
we're only 51 seconds in but 18 lies
yeah Trump would have won if you didn't
cheat then that's cheating
I don't know what you think shooting it
is actually some Grand conspiracy the
grand conspiracy is Democrats change the
rules yeah remember even uh Republican
legislatures also uh modified uh voting
rules to allow people to vote uh vote by
mail who wouldn't ordinarily be allowed
to it doesn't really matter but again
this is a reminder there's people we can
talk to reasonably and there's people we
can't that guy seems to be Beyond saving
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will actually talk about the
Joe Biden uh approval rating bump that
happened is it Ukraine is it the State
of the Union what is it we will talk
about U.S Olympic champion Brittany
Greiner being arrested and held in
Russia and we will talk about a man
sentenced to prison for using the covid
loan money that he got to buy Pokemon
cards Pokemon cards all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show I have
some coveted money fraud stories to tell
myself not of anything I did but just of
things I've caught wind of
um sign up at joinpakman.com get instant
access to the bonus show